Oh
hello so another day another game on the
play - app so now with the new version
there are some new features one of them
is that you can now choose months as
well as as years of age let me just show
that that's especially relevant in my
early years let's say it at 9 and 0
months I wasn't that good but if we go
to 9 and 10 months then I was quite a
bit stronger and I'm sure that many of
you will find it interesting to to watch
that little progression that I had them
so let's try let's try 14 today I think
that's more than difficult enough
I really have very little confidence so
let's go - 14 I'm not very confident I
think at that age - was very strong
tactically he's probably going to trick
me pretty badly we'll see what happens
I'm gonna play something pretty solid
this used to be one of my favorite lines
okay like this a few times when I was at
that age and I actually did this move
which is a bit inaccurate and this is
well
this is following game of mine against
Romanian Grandmaster Marion from 2000
and let's see how many years 2004 so I
think and now I have a pretty
comfortable position let's see what
happens mmm so
try and choose the best square for the
Queen I let me go to be six I like that
one if you like attacking the relatively
weak b2l so now this is a sort of a
strange move from nine is 14 the route
protects the pawn still protects the the
bishop but it's not comfortable here as
it may be pinned at any moment
I just need not to allow - a tricky
chance - to unpin the bishop but it's
actually not that easy to prevent it I'm
trying to define the best way
let me go for the most direct way moving
the bishop here and trying to exploit
the pain immediately mmm
maybe that was too hasty and it looks
like we got a message maybe I have a few
more friends than I thought continuing
pretty slowly
let me just go back with the bishop I
think I made a bit of mistake by putting
it on d7 it's usually better to
acknowledge your mistake so now might
get some counterplay against the e5
point I still like my position a lot
Green performs a dual function here
protecting the c4 pawn and the e5 pawn
now I'd like to go for this Bishop takes
Bishop and now we'll see I have a very
nice position two bishops better pawns
but it's not so easy to win
so just going to move this green one
square forward avoiding attacks with
bouquet 7 and I was at even threatening
to take on b2 deflecting his Queen and
then taking it roof next so now he's
moved his work away now I see no reason
not to put the palms in motion
so looks like his king is a little bit
weak so I'm trying to try and exploit
now let's bring the rook over this is
the problem with the fearless youth he's
not thinking at all about defending his
poor King he just wants to create
country play but I don't think he will
be successful
somehow I was about to fall for a little
trap I was going to put my Bishop on d5
thinking that if it takes the pawn then
I could land on Bishop to b7 attacking
both his rook and his night on d2 but I
think then he can play Knight to e4
attacking the Queen and thus avoiding
any immediate trouble so just gonna just
going to play more slowly now put the
rook on d3 that looks very nice
now it's a difficult choice I really
want to centralize the Queen put it on
d5 but on the other hand I might want
that square for for the bishop
I think I'm nevertheless going to put it
there so now your tax my queen but after
I retreat the Queen I have a very strong
threat of playing the brooked d2 which
will win his queen and frankly I don't
see that he has a good way to prevent
that now I think his rook moved to a8
was very dubious since now the route can
be attacked later on with Bishop d5 now
I have after he moves his King I must
have a myriad of of good good options I
think I'm just going to go for the
simplest one just noticed a trick if I
play the rope to d2 attacking his queen
putting the rook on the on the second
rank he might play rook to a7 attacking
my queen but alas that doesn't work for
several reasons first of all I can just
take the rook and then if he takes my
rook I play pawn to f4 and yes his
knight will be lost because of a pin so
now I play Queen to d3 and I cannot see
anything resembling a defense for him
work to a7 rook to e to Queen to c1 he's
still fighting attacking attacking my
bishop or she will take if I capture his
knight but I think if I just move move
the bishop there there is absolutely no
defense for for little - maybe taking
maybe taking the knight is even stronger
though I'm just going to go for that ah
- 14 realized that if he took the bishop
then I would return with the Brook to
the second rank and it would not last
long so now trying to force the exchange
of the rook rooks but now I will just be
a bishop up and there will be very
little question about the outcome of the
game now he can even exchange his rook
but now I am a bishop up and I wish
there was a offer your opponent's
resignation button there should be now
it's a very routine job and since these
pawns on the Queen side are blocked you
cannot even create a passed pawn over
there
now just put him in sucks when he loses
g4 pawn and he resigned the game and I
earned quite a lot of points I might be
playing myself in the play live
challenge we'll see well that's all for
now see you later